modifications have been made to the  treatment of Ebola patients in the  Democratic Republic of Congo patients  will now receive one of two  investigational Ebola treatments  it's Regeneron or maybe 114 the  preliminary results in 499 study  participants indicated that those  individuals receiving Regeneron or maybe  hundred 14 had a greater chance of  survival compared to those participants  with the other two these are great news  of course and these news will save lives  and moves us closer to finding an  effective treatment for Ebola so let's  not forget we now have a vaccine which  is highly efficacious we have treatment  which really ensures good data so  overall this is positive news and these  are great new tools or great tools for  our toolbox